apparently black black Twitter was
debating whether or not a guy should
order dessert on a first date or
appetizers I read this thread actually
from the girl
no dessert nor no appetizers she said I
would literally rather he order two
meals for himself then get dessert or
appetizer why I see this is women there
were upset it was a woman's initial
tweet and she was like I just don't know
why a man would order dessert that's for
me dessert an appetizer to some [ __ ] a
woman gets you as a man you eat meals
it's so funny you got a you got a really
respect black man that they are so
[ __ ] next-level
pimping women did they convince women to
make the bill less Yeah right like you
eliminated appetizers and dessert from a
potential date menu yeah but we didn't
convince them they came up we came up
with that by themselves but I think she
says I can order what's the next thing
she got tweeted about a real man would
cheat on his girl a real man go get some
[ __ ] outside the relationship that's
what a real man would do no more no but
they say they basically just saying it's
not masculine if a man orders dessert
that's what that's what it all boys you
don't [ __ ] the dessert gotta do why you
need some sweets on you a little
sweetness people on this podcast Indians
by far the worst bodies on the planet we
not masculine that's telling you I can't
handle no black [ __ ] hey hard beautiful
beloved there we go not as good wait a
minute this could be genius this could
be black women trying to get black
menace
dying from heart failure hypertension
and all these things you know that might
be geo black women y'all are really
[ __ ] the easiest line is I'd rather
you order two meals cause ain't nobody
gonna order two meals that's where you
like this is wild I'm not spending
another $20 on a more endless shrimp you
know I mean it's just analysts shrimp
we're good
that's a shot a black woman always
holding down black men man they really
found a way well maybe they just maybe
they just want to keep all the cheddar
Bay biscuits for themselves you know Bay
so are we I want to go to surgery is gay
she said it and I see ordering dessert
and it's kind of gay now that I think
about it I give you a small sum if you
were a milkshake and it got the whipped
cream on top and you eat the whipped
cream like this the whipped cream the
only way you eat that straight is you
drink the whole milkshake and it's at
the bottom and you scoop it out the side
yeah don't be going like this at the top
of it whipped cream into your [ __ ]
cheeks okay Abbi be all okay okay okay
now but the act of eating dessert what
about a masculine dessert an apple pie
with ice cream and apple pie a la mode
apple pie let me get a scoop ice cream
with that baby you know I'm thinking
like this glad that you say all the beep
I see me waitress glad that Allah mode
thank you after your first fight you got
back delicious oh can you take the first
bite fries okay alright but what about
if you just go straight straight Sunday
yeah yo I'm not open in a split but then
they like drizzle the chocolate on the
side it [ __ ] like that that's what they
do in the kitchen bro you just eaten it
yeah but then to eat it yeah but like
what if you just got some ice cream and
a little chocolate with the spoon so you
have to like strategically put the spoon
it is all everything straight apple pie
or I get straight like cookie or brownie
no ice cream nothing nothing creamy I
think creaminess is very gay Oh what if
you do this to me like this what if you
take a bite of the brownie but it's too
hot that's hilarious this is adria every
day what is coffees like make a little
confession when we would do comedy
coming up we will always go to a diner
afterward Veselka yeah and I can't tell
you how many times we split dessert me
Andrew sometimes other dudes see this
that's why you don't you don't call it
split dessert when is dudes even is
there you go
so we got dessert for the table yo you
want to split this yeah me and we're
gonna split dessert two spoons
hey you don't even need two spoons
you ate you - spewed you [ __ ] tug cos
it yeah yo [ __ ] you see you see why it's
gonna be what dessert is not what
dessert you could eat that's the least
game you just can't I'm out in the first
date but appetizers you can get me and
then another thing I was hypnotized is
wait a little hummus and yeah that
wasn't that bad she's okay appetizers
wasn't that big of a deal because
actually it's a flex is like oh [ __ ] you
got money cuz you will I get some apps
and you know we order an x-ray just
talking about food is a real topic right
funny cuz it's not gay at all but it's
like now you could be illegal in the
Middle East because this [ __ ] eating it
[ __ ] turn you might turn you dude you
for your boys eat hummus together you
both go in for a swipe and your [ __ ]
fingers touch yo you start the wrist
like this and obviously dog come on dude
but another thing that I don't know
where what does the house know but
another thing that this came from
nowhere cheesecake all of a sudden
cheesecake is the worst dessert ever
made why I don't know Kay this is black
Twitter it's like if you order
cheesecake you're a disgusting human
being yeah because y'all can't have milk
and sure y'all lactose and [ __ ] like
that it's just not a good it's not a
hero steak is delicious
you know that's [ __ ] Oh cuz ya'll Jr's
is that some [ __ ] that's like black
people [ __ ] I thought juniors was owned
by Italians but they but in your looks
like a Brooklyn thing like yo juniors
owned by Italian it's probably ain't my
black people I really thought it was
black establishment really
yeah maybe it is it was in the heart of
downtown before downtown was downtown
that's probably Jewish okay any other
appetizer that you could work
what if you order a shrimp scampi no
what if you not order shirts can't be uh
what does it call the shrimp cocktail
cocktail yell yeah come on son come on
yo lettuce wraps a PF Changs yay
you ordered us with your bros now you
can do a buffalo nah that's chicken it's
all over your face ain't it funny I
suddenly bring up Fried Chicken it's not
gay come on okay not as know there's
between a girl sucking dick important
and a guy eating fried chicken sound
what the sound no well that guys get as
into the popeyes chicken sandwich as any
porn star does it dick facts take this
year right to the face flex you don't
know it as you can say I'm so hey
chicken sandwiches go I do love the
sauce alright we learned something every
day but so you can't order apps or
dessert I'm a PA all right can I can I
ask questions yeah and I felt very
strongly about this I really had yo
salted rim drinks gay that seems a
little gone drink but that seems gay
then how you will do this let me look at
the people at home right Hey it just
asked me if I liked my picante here how
do you like your picante let me try it
that's not weird why would you make me
do that physical act are you actually
bows and licked the salt fit how you
supposed to get in you I thought it was
different oh he don't take no joy I was
like
I thought it was like I thought was like
an umbrella you're supposed to lick it
and then take a sip every single time
Wow oh yeah son they're [ __ ] tricking
us got to kill em yeah the salt I guess
goes well with tequila but you even
that's a keyless shot I never felt
comfortable doing that with the homies
pointage it in the drink yo what we need
salt you know it don't change the flavor
I never did a salt [ __ ] now I don't even
get a lime [ __ ] I look at your sir waive
your dude that needs a lot yeah so just
take that shot like a man huh not to
make this more gay but I can't fit all
day in my mouth welcome only gay is gay
you know is mad Gado true Roseboro yo
that's that dessert that's gay son she
Rose bro this was gay
cuz the true roses are covering that
brown sugar [ __ ] so not only you dipping
it in some liquid and then eating this
[ __ ] dick like substance after the
churros will you always do you write
about it you write about it you can't do
that oh yeah you can't anything
involving honey kind of gay that's the
key I mean you get all yo our pancakes
good Bobby it seems kind of it's the
masculine you know I mean it's hungry
jack yeah straightest cuz it's just like
a fat ass you just breaking it like yuck
yeah but you gotta you gotta eat the
full stack you can't individual like one
at a time
portion control
I don't say what he's saying you got a
knife through all three so you can't
separate them into saucers that are on
the plate is why that's right
crepes syrup comes out the wood okay
conversation it was silly and then you
just made it real gay yes bringing that
up is gay yes say what's wrong it's
sucking your own dick gay yes we're not
gonna have this conversation right now
this is not gonna be this is for patreon
yeah okay we're getting back to foods
that are gay okay in all seriousness in
all seriousness okay is melon gay
fruits I have no problem saying this
sound like melon so get it out is it cut
pineapple probably the gayest though I
love pineapple with that [ __ ] yeah he's
making it up the room get pineapple out
is that's not fair dawg I have a games
like the best fruit I know it's the best
but it's gay
he just is but you know I have any
points for it like like like listen
we're not just being home before we care
we need facts to back up our arguments
okay son it's just too fruity
I mean it's mad tropical like huh why it
makes your [ __ ] taste better which is
kind of straight that's the gays you
know no that's the straightest part of
the mom right because it gets your dick
sucked more by girls afterward my dudes
guys don't care what your comp tastes
like they just can't wait to suck it out
of your dick you think some guy who's
been waiting on the other side of a
glory hole for a [ __ ] an hour for a
dick to pop through so we could suck it
is worried about the flavor to come do
you think a girl is gonna be convinced
that I pineapple my caramel taste go do
you think a gay guy's gonna be like yeah
great let's go I don't think a guys care
about the taste to come I think they're
just too excited get it it's almost like
caviar some pie apples and berries a
little gay
for the Special K so what woman's a
serial Special K were they putting that
red berries berries yeah okay Special K
is not even gay come on yo come on yo
Special K like she'd especially eat some
corn
what Special K it's not [ __ ]
cornflakes unreleased no it's not
[Applause]